les chérubins chacun c'est-à-dire tout
cas ça vous va très bien je sais qu'il
ya votre femme dans les coulisses elle
était très je pense qu'elle a dû qui
fait allez adorer non mais franchement a
vraiment c'est un boulot de incroyable
mais embrasser les maquilleuses qui ont
un travail difficile et godié si vous
deviez est une personne de sexe
auparavant sur ye qui a three marceau
qui suit la pâte fimo libanais marceau
dans les sept centres slimane s'est pas
d'abord à mon arrivée non mais sérieux
marceau un qui fait un jeu qui s'amorce
au final d'ailleurs ma famille ressemble
un peu d'ailleurs chaque femme à quai à
slimane
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le cas
arabi savoie les coûts seraient deux
jeunes femmes ou alors ne le prenez
surtout pas pour la flagornerie c'est
promis j'aimerais mettre votre épouse
parce que j'aurai avère être un jour à
la source de la création j'aurais eu
huit la femme secrète comme ça ou de
dali voilà est à vos côtés et voir tout
le temps les fulgurances que vous avez
vu ce qu'on appelle le mozart du paf et
voir comment commence à se mêler le un
génie travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a mon avis oui mais vous foutez de ma
gueule va durer combien de temps cette
affaire un peu un petit peu voilà très
bien merci
j'ai juste une info insolite c'est la
coupe de jean michel meyer
[Rires]
la faute à qui c'est pas mal mais c'est
pas mal acquis non c'est la faute à qui
la faute à qui
bon oui bonjour
[Applaudissements]
si j'étais une femme se serait emma
watson et ben maxwell a une carrière de
soi elle est à la fois française et
anglaise se réveille alors au site et y
donneront pas du tout mais j'ai un bon
accent anglais alors à lisa
[Applaudissements]
en réalité je connais bien les
différences entre les ressembler l ex
enfant américain avec 100 blessés que
peuvent-ils pas ce que vous avez fait
une jean-michel meilleurs costumes très
distinguée et vous avez les versions
américaine sait un peu plus sur l'homme
[Applaudissements]
sur les quais vous mes amis quand mme
bale a passé plus du whisky le combat de
la part de l'amf non mais sans déconner
je lui ressemble plus à du bébé né de la
codi noyon sang peut s'amuser de whisky
comme vous si vous étiez un homme
poignets avec la poitrine sans réfléchir
florent pagny très belle voix pas moi
pas parce qu'il est tout le monde à
l'usure vers doit défendre cette manne
en revanche mais ça vieillit moins le
préconil parce que je suis contre mais
sinon j'adore cette façon d'avancer dans
la vie c'est vrai me faire chier
personne ne voulant pas qu'on le fasse
chier j'adore ça et vous aux fans dois
l'avouer très mimi mathy phares comme
c'est pouvoir réguler
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]